hi
we're gonna watch brooklyn nine-nine
today what's the numbers john it's
episode seven of season two i'll answer
the episode hey if you guys can hit that
like button that'd be cool
and if you want to go ahead and
subscribe and click notification bells
be cool we'll leave watch once receive
the time codes out of patreon
and uh it's cool a bunch of shows over
there at the same time you get the
option for a reaction house watch logs
include two all of them are cool and uh
hey thanks to the boys are proud for
hurting us down yeah the boys are cool
all right guys let's do it let's do this
dude it's cool
[Music]
morning who are those for
captain holt's uncle passed away i
wanted to do something
flowers are a bold choice santiago but i
can still beat you
beat me at expressing condolences yep
it's on
i think a thoughtful email is the way to
go here dear captain we were all so
sorry for your loss group sentiment very
meaningful
hey did you send that from your personal
or work account personal so you
remembered to turn off your signature
right
i don't know
oh no
dear captain we were all so sorry for
your loss please let us know if there's
anything we can do sent from
my stinky butt i was hacked thank you
for the email it means a lot to me
you're very welcome i was addressing
your stinky butt
it's okay he's got a nifty knit tie now
progress i'm sorry what
i just made the greatest observation to
be made about this show probably ever
and you missed it
captain and i are going to a charity
event in brighton beach have a great
thanksgiving peralta will be the officer
in command jake in charge no look
five woo
anyway thank you for taking command of
the precinct over the holiday not a
problem as you all know i hate
thanksgiving the pilgrims were murderers
and turkey taste like napkins
feel bad that i was chosen over amy
actually captain asked me first but i
had plans teddy brewed at thanksgiving
pilsner and it's bottling day bottling
day why'd you come in at all day it's
one 12-hour shift what are you afraid is
gonna happen injury death general
calamity just don't burn the place down
you can count on me sir happy
thanksgiving turkey day sorry boyle
what can i do for you gina i would like
to answer the phone always just like
uh-huh done charles this precinct
wideband and me saying the word
succulent done i want to work in the
break room so i don't have to hear
charles say succulent done done denzel
washington
oh so your plan is to not take this
seriously at all oh i am as serious as a
heart attack no offense scully yeah mine
are never that serious i call them
oopsies
thanks for coming to this event sergeant
i'm always happy to spend time with you
certainly
plus the longer i stay out of my house
today the better brother-in-law zeke is
in town oh
no
calls you tiny terry also teensy terry
teeny weeny terry berry and little
dum-dum you know it's the lack of effort
on that last one that really gets me
if you wanted to get out of the house
why don't you just volunteer to run the
precinct instead of peralta i'd much
rather have you in charge don't worry
about jake he's gonna do great he can be
very responsible okay the elevator door
is the goal try and score on me
succulent bossing jakey i'm gonna go
home and stuff my goose
oh
what is that powder
i don't know i don't know what do we do
cocaine god
okay everyone we are in lockdown oh no
oh jeepers now apparently three other
precincts received similar packages this
month and they were all baking powder
nevertheless hazmat has to run a quick
test but i anticipate we'll all be out
of here momentarily in the meantime i
suggest we turn this lockdown into a pop
in lockdown
what are you doing this is a crisis i'm
trying to keep morale up because hazmat
said it's almost definitely a hoax
almost what if it's anthrax we are all
100 gonna die
he got trapped out on the balcony i
don't like him alone out there not with
his history i mean what if he gets up on
a lid
he's got a worm living in his ear that
affects his balance oh well then he's
not truly alone out there right
peralta seems to have it under control
he said things were dope i want to
monitor the situation i need to get
somewhere with an internet connection
and a landline you live out here do you
have a home office well yeah but zeke is
in that room perfect let's go there
or as he calls it
tiny terry's hobbit hole
[Laughter]
we ran our test and it's not baking
powder there's a chance it's toxic what
oh no
we know it's not baking powder what is
it we don't know yet sir but we are sir
you shouldn't have to be below eye level
so i'm gonna hold you
we should start rationing the food now
and we should tell people that we're in
for a long night because the substance
is not baking powder whoa whoa that's
just gonna freak everyone out we want
people to be happy and calm
we should play them shade
i'm not there to read the situation but
i did leave peralta in charge oh sir one
other thing hitchcock got trapped out on
the balcony good sounds like we dodged a
bullet there yeah
sergeant is there any way you can
replace this large ball with a chair
that is actually a chair it's good for
your back man
but it's good for your core yes my core
it's engaged
sir you remember my brother-in-law zeke
yes hello hey
good he's gone now let's get serious and
focus up
just trying to get to the printer
hey hey hey people
how about everyone come on bring it in
here gather round so
we are still awaiting the initial test
results but hopefully we'll hear soon
that it's all harmless and we can all go
home soon
what are you doing
here it's what a number two does it was
way too close can you say it quietly to
me please this is going really well okay
at any rate
and do something fun maybe a movie night
our options are a bootleg copy of the
diane keaton classic something's got to
give movie's hilarious okay surprising
opinion we'll talk about that later
[Laughter]
why don't we have a talent show then who
has a special talent oh i just learned a
single ladies dance hey yes
[Laughter]
those hips limber charles
boyle really knows how to move his
pelvis i can't believe this is one of
the last things i'm ever gonna see
actually with anthrax the last things
you'll see will be doctor blood
this is why i became a cop really
lawyer guy is doing stand-up it's got
really good material
there are two jobs where you have total
control over the people that pay you
president of a country
and cleaning lady
i can't believe you gave the mob a
megaphone okay first of all we didn't
have a mic and second it's not a mob
it's a happy group of unlikely friends
oh no people are starting to get hungry
oh okay not a problem parade the vending
machine
voila thanksgiving feast from the two
delivery guys who were trapped in here
with us
[Laughter]
what about me
uh
i guess i could have a friend throw some
pretzels up to you from the street and
soda too fine i'll have someone blindly
throw ice-cold metal cans of soda
we're freezing in here we want heat
we want heat we want heat we want heat i
need to go find a couple bags
charles and i arrested a guy a couple of
years ago that was selling knock-off
designer coats just gotta find the box
they're in and everyone will be warm and
happy oh oh no i need to man up man up
sexist i'm sorry but i don't see gender
sir
[Laughter]
zeke i'm sorry but captain thinks we're
gonna have to use your room for a little
longer no problem really yeah i feel you
i got a boss as a jerk like that too
right captain's the worst
sometimes i call them
hold the dope
that's cold stay tough brother
brothers oh
brother
i will brother
this is gonna backfire oh no see you
brother
stop
dude stop saying it chill
yeah i was not able to find any heat
because it's more of a concept
[Laughter]
i'm leaving i'm walking out that door
jake you have to arrest him no it'll
only make things worse look we're doing
this my way i'm the captain now
hey excuse me sir hi can i talk to you
in my office for a sec it's nothing
serious just a fun chat look if you
don't come with me she's gonna arrest
you hey are you guys whispering
[Laughter]
the hazmat guys did run some preliminary
tests and the substance is not baking
powder so i'm asking for your help to
keep this thing quiet so we can have the
chillest biohazard lockdown in brooklyn
yeah of course i understand no
uh-huh uh-oh
if you talk to people he's gonna get in
the megaphone i'm gonna just go oh why
is he standing on that chair hey
everyone they lied to us it's friggin
anthrax
oh my god
oh whatcha making a snack oh a captain
wants four sandwiches a spoonful of mayo
spread evenly middle loaf pieces of
bread only
what an ass
tell me about it brother
i almost forgot he wants a whole pie too
this dude is the worst
i don't always understand problems
they're still waiting on the lab and
it's all's good then a box with a
question mark inside another box with
the question mark another box with a
question mark another box with a
question mark another box you gotta
upgrade your phone dog this is a human
rights violation you can't keep us here
i'm 23. i'm a celebrity and today i'm
gonna die not one word of that is true
oh hitchcock's bleeding he got hit in
the head with a soda can he never saw it
coming ugh we have to start putting
people in detention we have to quash
this no we need them to calm down we
need to put on something's got to give
great idea great movie
probably put out that
heat that's what i thought they were
gonna do with the jackets
so
captain i have some news
what happened well remember
jeffords and i will come right away i'm
very disappointed in you
no
he said he's very disappointed in you oh
man
look i screwed up and i think you should
take over command of the precinct been
waiting to hear you say that all day i
know which is why you shouldn't say it
you're still trying to make people happy
be a leader and tell me what you need me
to do tell everyone what you need them
to do you're the captain jake
i'm the captain now
captain philip captain phillip
right yeah
[Laughter]
scully i need you to help boyle don't
worry about hitchcock he'll be fine i
once saw him fall down three flights of
stairs get up and keep eating his hot
dog like nothing happened
[Music]
the copy room is now a detention center
for anyone who gets out of line i'm just
gonna go downstairs and thank your
family for accommodating us
you will do nothing of the sort zeke is
being nice to me for the first time ever
because he thinks you're a jerk just
like his boss when we go downstairs i
want you to scream at me and this will
make you happy it's the best
thanksgiving gift you could give me what
an idiotic thing to say what's a
thanksgiving gift
i'm just getting in the zone
the powder was not harmful
[Applause]
[Laughter]
actually we're trying to clean up your
cap and so unless you have something
meaningful to contribute you can get the
hell out
oh right sorry you weren't here when i
switched up my management style that
must be so confusing for you
happy thanksgiving guys jake happy
turkey day guys i'll be in my office
oh boy
ah
and rascals
ladies and gentlemen we just watched an
episode about how john would handle such
a situation hahaha
that's right
i would not attempt to address the
situation whatsoever just all people
pleasing 100 percent
and uh that's what we're going to run in
i'm just going to yes after that yeah
should we play a game
i mean we can make this fun
come
guys
johnny you got to stand up you got to
don't light the jackets on you got to
learn some leadership skills and
taking this she needs you to do for me
right now
[Laughter]
yes i i know i know i was way out of
line i'm so sorry
one more for good measure there we go
all right
that'll teach me
yeah man
that's a tough position to be in
i can imagine
you can i feel like i've been in
something before
where
i had to take charge
of a
group of people
that it wasn't like a quarantine
situation
something in my memory tells me that i
was once in a position that emotionally
reminded me of such a predicament
um i don't know were you were you abroad
were you out prison riot
riot of course you organized the inmates
right and i kept trying to be the funny
guy and i was like we're never going to
get out of here if i keep making jokes
no just find the biggest strongest dude
and make him laugh his ass off and
you've got power throughout the
prison yeah
yeah that immunity that's uh
all right you've done like i've done
like group things before and back then
it's like sometimes you're leading a
group of people you gotta you can't
always just try to be the funny guy
and even though it's tempting to just be
like i want to be michael scott from the
office
i mean you don't want it you want to be
him but successful yeah
actually making everyone laugh
yeah
but to be in a position like that where
it's like you're afraid of getting stern
and having everyone turn against you
like you want to be likable that's hard
that's tough it is tough it's always a
feeling to fight against
one time i did have to kick people out
of a party that was not mine but i said
i would help
and i kicked a whole bunch of people out
of the party
and the whole time i was like sorry
everyone sorry sorry then afterwards i
was like i shouldn't have said sorry all
the time
it makes me look weak
i don't even want to be doing this
now because i'm so sorry i think
everyone uh i think one person who's
been like why do you keep saying sorry
like someone i didn't know
and i was like yeah i just felt bad to
kick them out apart it wasn't even mine
i was trying to help a friend out you
should have just looked at them dead in
the eyes and said
i'm sorry go home fun's over
sorry not sorry
yeah yeah
you learn things anyway it's okay enough
about me
let's talk about john yes yeah yeah yeah
yeah
i would mean tiny i'm tiny terry
and then you know
a little bit
yeah
people always be taking my sandwiches
and belittling me for my stature
i get that this episode's theme soon to
be about how to handle intimidation yeah
yeah and situations that feel beyond
your control
it's tough when you have like
more physically imposing person around
you i get that way around people who are
just taller than me
a lot of times when i first meet them i
have to do like a little check in my
head
i'm like oh i'm getting like i feel like
a younger brother all of a sudden and i
need to kind of watch myself and not
just
not just
say yes and do everything they want or
put myself less than them in my own head
and then i behave it happens all the
time for me it's it's like work around
process i gotta do
uh where i
it's like we have a cory from double
toasted that happened to me oh he's tall
and i had to like step away for a bit
and be like
what's happening in your brain cut it
out is that a wedding
there's a firefighter there
tall guy alpha personality
but i don't like when people try to get
bossy around me then i get upset
ooh why what happened but what bossy
thing happened second someone's like
let's go this way come here
when i'm like don't tell me
i'm part of this group that's just the
little group circle of the big event
that we're around yeah oh my god what do
you think i'm gonna potentially i'm not
gonna go with you now just because you
talked to me that way yeah yeah that's
fair yeah you don't want to be barked at
but i can i can see that though with
like it's his brother-in-law right
yeah man that's tough that can be rough
if it's olivia's brother i i if he's
watching i will do whatever he wants
just bumping he's a scary [ __ ] guy i
will not mess with it he's scary tall
long ass beard
okay yeah so you're tiny times
i'm a little woodland elf at that moment
yeah
uh well i want to see you in a little
elf hat pointy ears yeah thanks man
you're welcome
anyway john how do you relate to the
situation
but gina is mostly who i would be you
know just you know right i have lots of
vulnerability
show your heart once in a while
uh i don't know i guess i would probably
be santiago or boyle in this situation
for reals i would probably be not put in
the charge but the woman is like i don't
know we're gonna figure this out or
something cause i'm i'm better at those
things when i'm not put in that seat i
guess
and i wouldn't just be like i want to
[ __ ] lead the station
so yeah i would probably be
i don't know it depends on the day i
would be santiago or boyle i guess
because you know boyle you know eager to
please eager to help it's very much me
uh but also you know a little bit likes
as much as i'm i wouldn't describe
myself as straight laced i can be
attentive to protocols and things like
that depending so uh
you know and uh when called upon in a
clutch you know i can
i can give a little splash of like oh
here i've taken a look at this situation
with fresh eyes and uh here maybe try
this
or no or i would be hitchcock
let's get stuck on the balcony
and just be locked out of the lockdown
he said like guys
can't he go can't he climb down a fire
escape or something you would think but
i mean he's not gonna figure that
he's not gonna be that limber or that uh
you're proactive
whereas i love that line
i once saw him fall down a flight of
stairs five five three four flights of
stairs
the writing of that joke so funny is
because he doesn't establish at the
beginning that he has a hot dog
yes
yeah yeah yeah
into that that one line so it's like
what a funny ass line because then you
have to imagine the ingenuity with which
he protected the hotdog
it's
yeah man respect the dog this is so
funny how a joke like that can be not as
funny if you establish like i once i'm
eating a hot dog then fall down a flight
of stairs
like the reveal that he's had hockey so
it's it's isn't that weird one critical
sentence yeah yeah it's a subtle mislead
key piece of context withheld for
comedy's sake dude comedy i wish we saw
the scene i wonder if it's deleted where
yeah
all black people are the same i'm sorry
but all
mexicans
definitely
most certainly they are and asians
asians are all whites yeah
middle every races
really yeah
but not all black people not every other
armenians yes all the same they're all
the same
but not black people nope all jewish
people are the same
um
people
us
how much of a whole cannot dig here with
this jerk
come to a crossroads in this improv game
do i yes end this at the risk of being
violently misunderstood
watch a whole comedy show make a couple
of edgy jokes that are not even that
edgy yeah but then but then like this
racist but then you can make a career
off of complaining about how people
listen to comedy
and that's the real dream
i'd love to have a protest going yeah
dude i'd love to have a place and then
come out here and be like guys
i'm standing for free speech have a
bunch of people with my millions of
dollars on netflix i have a bunch of
people complaining about racism and then
people defending me yeah
like comedy
racism i would just go out to that crowd
of the people defending you like guys
let me just apologize
guys these were jokes
literally they're not that important
they're actually that important i
literally hit a nerve here
and let me apologize this no comedy show
should come to this i made jokes about
people that are not me let me go
apologize to them right now
next special i'll be sure to make fun of
literally everyone so that no one's left
out and everyone's offended i would just
say
i'm sorry that i hurt your feelings
that doesn't mean i can't promise you
i'm not going to make another joke that
might hurt your feelings
that's about as simple as i would make
it that's that's that's a fair approach
among a few families like i tried it was
just a joke
clearly really upset you
no you're a philosopher at that point
every stand-up if you get paid to do
comedy you're a modern philosopher i
know he's having a movement there man
him joe rogan all those guys man once
you ascend the mountain
yeah i love when you put on that joe
rogan dave chappelle podcast
three and a half hours of no comedy oh
that sounds fun
[Laughter]
thank you comedians oh buddy
he's actually liked was it good
on the one hand i'm like i could see
that being a very interesting
conversation on the other hand i could
see that conversation disappearing so
far up the anus of self-serious comedy
you know it's a real split
there's a little bit of life stuff and
everything you know it's not just about
like comedy and all that that's what
somebody talking about actually i know i
really liked the podcast that they did
to be honest
hey problematic figures aside i can
absolutely see why
yeah man
dave chappelle still makes me laugh you
can't lie yeah i can't lie about that
but i'll never do a reaction anything he
does
just because i don't want to get called
out for laughing at a certain joke maybe
i shouldn't have left him
but put it on record here
i didn't specify which joke yeah yeah it
could be from one of the really old
specials yeah yeah before it was
problematic yeah before you said
anything that's him yeah
about any group of people
one day i'll watch the news special
see what all the fuss is about i know
sometimes people can pick up on what
you're saying hmm
like one time
i watched this movie
and i was like well it's woke
it's woke it's woke there was like a few
seconds i had to
close my eyes at that's what i said
everyone knew what i was talking about
oh god no
i was talking about nothing in there and
i was like damn how'd they know i
finally heard that take too and i was
like oh sorry you heard me say that why
would you invite this upon yourself greg
alba you should how did you not i
thought if i to just keep that one in
your pocket i thought if i didn't
specify it be better
do better that people wouldn't know
yeah yeah clearly that works
clearly
in a movie that's already had so much
global controversy for a particular
scene or i think i knew
how i responded and i said that just to
provoke some people yeah you know that's
also a response some people double down
you know yeah you double down i closed
my eyes the entire eternals
i was knocking my turtlenecks i was just
oh my god
the fact that there were so many asians
in trump i was like i gotta i gotta go i
need to take a break my eyes can only
handle so long oh is that ben kingsley
oh he's he's part white right it's like
running on the treadmill you know once
again you just gotta go oh man let me
just take a little breather here yeah
yeah
where's razor fist oh good breath of
fresh air
that's normal yes definitely definitely
hey can we get
can we get another first mcu sex scene
really really got to applaud them for
for that you know it's wonderful but but
gotta close my eyes though yeah during
other stuff that's offensive
but guys listen to me
are we listening
everyone's listening brooklyn 99 was a
good episode people usually skip the
reaction and come to this part i hope
you do you [ __ ]
[Laughter]
comment below if you're offended by
being called an [ __ ] at the end of
the video
guys subscribe
with that
hit that like button let's do a pic
chris wim off if anybody at our patreon
would probably be the most capable of
handling a situation like this one it's
you buddy i mean we were joking during
the review about how we might handle it
but let's be fair greg would probably do
an okay job i probably wouldn't but you
would do a great job because you are
attentive you care about the people
around you not just the people who can
benefit you directly or who you have a
prior relationship to you could bring
warring factions together placate
everybody's needs without coddling them
chris you could give them what they need
versus what they went
wham off so
keep that about you that quality never
let that flame die out and hey this
thanksgiving since this is a technical
thanksgiving episode we're thankful for
you buddy so i hope you're thankful that
we're thankful and if you are thankful
then stay pledged which i mean you know
you haven't wavered yet so thank you
doubly thankful for you take care and
hey i hope it's not anthrax
whammy
[Music]